est ce qu'il y ait des indépendants dans
la salle
lever la main les indépendants
je vois pas bien mais je vois quand même
quelques mains qui se lèvent est-ce que
parmi vous il y en a qui ont déjà
expérimenté comores king une main demain
en fait le coworking ça repose sur deux
principes
le premier principe partager des espaces
de travail et vous former un réseau une
communauté et ce réseau va favoriser les
échanges va favoriser l'entr'aide va
favoriser la créativité
c'est une idée toute simple et on se
demande même comment ça se fait qu'on
n'y a pas pensé avant le coworking
c'était en 2005 à san francisco et en
fait ce qui a favorisé l'émergence du
coworking c'est l'essor des nouvelles
technologies
maintenant avec votre ordinateur vous
êtes devenu complètement mobile vous
pouvez aller n'importe où un clic et
vous avez accès à tout votre bureau et
vous avez accès à toute l'information à
toutes les connaissances du monde c'est
l'équivalent de bibliothèques entières
et vous êtes connecté au monde entier
dans ces conditions vous pouvez vous
mettre n'importe où pour aller
travailler
est-ce qu'il y en a parmi vous qui
prennent le train le matin moi j'ai pris
pendant pas mal de temps le train et
j'ai été frappé de voir
comme avant même d'arriver au travail la
plupart des gens sont déjà en train de
travailler avec leur ordinateur dans le
train alors les trains ne sont pas des
espaces de coworking
mais qui sait peut-être un jour ça va
devenir des espaces de coworking en fait
tout est possible je continue à
l'application est-ce qu'il y en a parmi
vous qui sont abonnés à mobility
personnes
avant vous avez tort à moi j'ai
expérimenté ça pendant deux ans parce
que j'avais plus de voiture et c'est
absolument génial d'abord j'avais des
voitures beaucoup mieux que celle que
j'ai maintenant et puis et puis j'avais
zéro souci donc voilà je vous encourage
à vous intéresser à ce que propose
mobility
peut-être que j'aurais plus de succès
avec ma deuxième question est-ce qu'il y
en a parmi vous qui ont déjà vécu ou qui
vivent actuellement en colocation
les souvenirs d'étudiants peut-être
ok alors quand vous aurez expérimenté
mobility et quand vous avez vécu en
colocation en fait vous viviez vous
pratiquiez l'économie collaborative
l'économie collaboratif c'est un état
d'esprit
en fait ça se base sur la consommation
et ça se base sur le mode de vie quand
vous partagez une voiture vous êtes dans
la consommation collaborative en vous
propose un bien plutôt que de l'acheter
vous l'utilisez on optimise les
ressources quand vous vivez en
colocation vous êtes dans un mode de vie
collaboratif plutôt que d'avoir chacun à
son appartement on partage le même
appartement on partage la cuisine on
partage le salon en fait le ménage à
tour de rôle c'est un mode de vie
collaborative en mutualisent les
ressources avec le coworking on est dans
la même logique dans un espace de
coworking
vous avez des places de travail vous
avez une connexion wifi vous avez une
photocopieuse imprimante scanner une
cuisine où vous pouvez vous faire à
manger enfin bref tout ce qu'il vous
faut pour travailler en compagnie
d'autres corps coeur le coworking c'est
une réponse à la crise économique
l'économie collaborative aussi ce sont
des réponses à la morosité ambiance ce
sont des réponses à la méfiance et à la
défiance comment ça se passe dans un
espace de coworking dans un espace de
coworking vous allez chercher et trouver
la solution qui vous convient la plupart
du temps les corps car ce sont des
indépendants il ya plusieurs types
d'indépendants vous pouvez être
indépendant à fond et avoir besoin d'une
certaine régularité d'une structure mais
pas forcément être prêt à investir dans
des structures fixes et très coûteuse
donc vous choisissez de venir à plein
temps dans un espace de corps qui vous
avez votre bureau vous pouvez disposer
d'un meuble de rangement et vous avez
tous les outils technologiques de base
nécessaires pour pouvoir mener à bien
votre travail mais peut-être que vous
n'avez pas envie de passer tout votre
temps dans un espace de coworking comme
vous l'aviez peut-être fait dans une
autre moi je l'avais fait par exemple
dans une autre vie en travaillant dans
un bureau
ça m'a pas tellement contenu en fait
donc dans un espace de coworking vous
pouvez aussi choisir de venir
pour casser un peu la solitude du
travail à la maison pour rencontrer
d'autres personnes pour confronter vos
avis avec les avis des autres comores
caire vous pouvez venir à la mi temps
quand on est indépendants on peut se
retrouver aussi dans une configuration
où on est très occupé on doit beaucoup
bouger et on a besoin de solutions qui
soient flexibles dans mon espace de
coworking vous pouvez choisir de venir à
la journée il ya des packs de quatre
journées dix journées et à ce moment là
quand vous en avez besoin vous vous
inscrivez sur un agenda online et vous
réservez votre place à l' espace de
coworking tout cela vous pouvez le
variées sur du long terme ou sur du
court terme et quand vous avez trouvé la
bonne formule comment ça se passe dans
un espace de coworking
en principe quand vous arrivez dans un
espace de coworking c'est pour
travailler et bien je vous assure que
certains jours je défie la personne qui
démarre à l'espace 500 dit à martigny de
savoir si dans les locaux il y à une 3
ou 10 personnes qui travaillent on
entendrait voler des mouches c'est la
concentration est à son maximum c'est
comme dans une bibliothèque chacun est
concentré dans son travail est
d'ailleurs souvent les coureurs car me
disent que c'est la concentration du
voisin qui déteint sur lui et qui lui
permet d'aller jusqu'au bout de son
travail et d'avancer et de pas se
laisser distraire par toutes sortes de
choses d'autres jours c'est une
véritable ruche ça discute dans tous les
sens ça échange en fait dans un espace
de coworking vous avez toute une
communauté de ressources des gens qui
sont complémentaires les gens qui ont
envie d'échanger les gens qui ont des
talents et un moment donné forcément ces
gens rentrent en contact et ces gens
échangent ces échanges peuvent prendre
plusieurs sortes dans mon espace de
coworking
j'ai une personne qui sera peut-être
appelé un jour à faire rapport
d'activité sur son travail sur sa petite
entreprise
pour bien faire elle va décider de le
faire en français et en allemand
elle parle allemand elles maîtrisent
l'allemand ya pas de problème elle
prépare son rapport d'activité et puis
au dernier moment elle se dit quand même
l'allemand c'est pas ma langue
maternelle ce serait bien que je puisse
trouver quelqu'un qui me relis ce tout
ça est un traducteur dans mon espace de
coworking elle va cette personne va lui
demander de jeter un petit coup d'oeil
sur son travail d'avoir un petit
feedback de faire quelques corrections
éventuellement ce traducteur ça fait pas
très longtemps qu'il a installée et puis
depuis quelques temps il a commencé à
s'organiser pour faire son site internet
il a rencontré un webmaster qui est en
train de lui de faire le travail avec
lui mais c'est pas simple de faire un
site internet même que vous avez
quelqu'un qui lui fait vous devez
fournir des textes des fournir des
images et c'est ce qui se passe pour lui
et un moment donné il savait plus très
bien il disait bon les images que ce que
je mets et qu'est-ce que je ne peux m
com onglet que ce qu'il ya comme un
thème etc
depuis peu il ya un webmaster qui
fréquentent l'espace du courrier alors
c'est pas lui qui va faire le site du
traducteur mais par contre quand il l'a
entendu parler de ces problèmes avec son
site il a donné des conseils il lui a
dit fais attention mais pas trop de
textes faire en sorte que chaque page
soit bien accessible facilement que
l'internaute savent toujours où il en
est dans le site ça lui a rendu de
précieux services ce webmaster comme il
est nouveau il vient d'ouvrir sa boîte
defer sa start up quand il a des mandats
pour des clients
et bien des fois il a un peu coincé avec
les histoires de graphisme parce que
c'est pas son métier le graphisme lui
peut faire la programmation s'occuper de
piste ya derrière mais le graphisme
c'est un métier aussi et c'est pas le
sien et ya pas de graphiste dans mon
espace de coworking mais bon il a quand
même essayé de demander aux autres est
ce que par hasard tu connaîtras un
graphiste qui pourrait me donner un coup
de main et moi je connais un graphiste
avec qui je travaille régulièrement et
je lui ai donné l'adresse de ce
graphiste et désormais ils travaillent
avec ce graphiste et ce graphiste un
jour il aura peut-être besoin d'une
traduction et ça continue à circuler
comme ça dans tous les sens c'est pas
des gros jobs n'y a pas de circulation
d'argent on est dans l'antre aide pure
et simple moi j'étais d'un jour demain
c'est toi qui est quelqu'un d'autre et
puis après demain ce quelqu'un d'autre
va peut-être me renvoyer l'ascenseur ça
c'est une formule celle entraide elles
se passent d'une façon très informelle
quasiment tous les jours une autre
formule c'est le troc vous savez tous
que c'est que le troc il se trouve que
dans les gens qui fréquentent les
espaces de coworking ya très souvent des
gens qui sont dans la communication et
quand on écrit des textes ça peut être
utile de pouvoir se les faire relire moi
j'écris des textes
dans la boîte où je bossais avant
j'avais des relecteurs officiel payé
pour faire ça maintenant j'ai plus
personne alors j'ai des gens qui se
demandent est ponctuellement mais ils
sont pas toujours là ils n'ont pas
toujours le temps il ya une autre
personne à l'espace simples en huit qui
fait la communication et qui écrit et
bien régulièrement on se fait relire nos
textes c'est du troc alors le traducteur
avec son site internet il s'est dit il
faut que je fasse une campagne google
adwords seulement il n'a jamais fait ça
les réseaux sociaux c'est pas tellement
content rue et donc du coup il en a
parlé et puis s'est rendu compte qu'il y
avait une spécialiste en communication
sur le web donc là comme elle est très
occupée elle va pas pouvoir reprendre du
temps vraiment sur son son temps de
travail professionnel pour lui faire sa
campagne aux devoirs mais ils ont
discuté d'un prix ils se sont mis
d'accord et puis finalement le
traducteur a engagé la responsable en
communication sur le web pour lui faire
sa campagne google adwords qui sont les
personnes concernées par le court king
comme je voulais dit tout à l'heure
principalement des indépendants j'ai eu
l'occasion au début de l'année
d'accueillir un chef d'entreprise il
avait une pme d'environ 30 personnes en
fait il est venu me voir parce qu'il
voulait me vendre ses services internet
donc il est venu là il y avait d'autres
comme hors pair qui étaient là on a pris
un verre ensemble on a commencé à
discuter et il a trouvé ça assez sympa
d'avoir toutes ses ressources dans un
même endroit il se trouve que au même
moment il était en train de faire une
formation post grad et ils devaient
rédiger une publication c'était un jeune
père de famille chez lui impossible de
trouver du temps pour être tranquille
pour faire ça au boulot il était tout le
temps dérangé par ses collaborateurs
donc il a décidé de venir à l'espace
simplon vite pour travailler sa
publication il est venu il a pris un
abonnement de quatre journées il ya
flexible il est venu quand ça l'arrangé
et finalement ça lui a été très utile
pendant quatre journées complètes de ne
pouvoir se consacrer qu'à ça il a fait
des échanges aussi avec les autres
personnes je ne sais pas s'il a vendu
ses services internet à d'autres
personnes mais c'est pas exclue en
dehors de ça il peut y avoir des
directeurs des managers qui à un moment
donné dans leur vie ont besoin de
prendre du recul par rapport à
l'entreprise dans un espace de coworking
on fonctionne à l'horizontale ya pas de
hiérarchie y'a pas de fonctionnement
verticale n'y a pas de compétition il
n'y a pas de jugement ça change pour un
chef d'entreprise vous imaginez les
pressions les tensions quand on a toute
une équipe à qui l'on peut se confier
quand on a des problèmes personne c'est
la jungle ya peut-être des gens qui
rêvent de vous piquer votre place pas
évident dans un espace de coworking rien
de tous ces problèmes il peut venir
travailler il peut échanger avec les
autres courts qui a trouvé des solutions
à ces problèmes
avoir des avis complètement d'intérêt
désintéressé et même on a un spécialiste
en innovation dans notre espace de
coworking et bien je peux vous dire
qu'il en a fournit déjà des solutions à
nombre de gens qui sont venus là qu'ils
soient des comores père qu'il soit les
clients décor au caire où qu'ils soient
des simples visiteurs et puis il ya
aussi des gens qui font du home office
si vous êtes amené à travailler à vous
habitez martini vous êtes amené à
travailler à lausanne ou à genève
peut-être que si vous avez à saint
patron saint pie vous dira ok un jour
par semaine tu peux travailler à la
maison alors vous commencez à faire du
home office chez vous sauf que vous
n'avez pas forcément l'habitude de
travailler comme indépendant vous allez
pas forcément l'habitude de vous donner
un cadre une discipline et que c'est pas
évident en plus les gens autour de vous
si vous êtes à la maison ils ont pas
dans l'idée que vous travaillez c'est
que vous êtes disponible pour les
enfants c'est pareil qu'après vous êtes
tentés d'aller dans le frigo en fait y'a
plein de tentations à la maison la
solution ça peut être effectivement
devenir un jour par semaine travailler
dans un espace de cours évidemment il
faut pas des espaces de coworking soir
brigue ou abou petit spa sinon vous avez
rien résolu mais si vous avez un espace
de coworking à côté de chez vous c'est
une excellente solution que d'aller
travailler un jour par semaine de faire
du home office un peu en dehors du
groupe en tête maintenant j'aimerais
qu'on fasse une petite expérience
j'aimerais vous demander d'imaginer que
vous venez de monter votre boîte de
production d'événements votre boîte
d'événementiel vous êtes vous travailler
tout seul et vous avez décidé de prendre
une formule mi temps dans un espace de
coworking les coworkers c'est vous les
autres commentaires c'est vous toutes
les personnes qui vous trouvez ici et à
la fin de la soirée les organisateurs de
tête viens de vous dire on sait que vous
avez une boîte d'événementiel
nous on a beaucoup trop de choses c'est
devenu trop lourd l'organisation de
cette journée on aimerait que vous nous
organiser et la soirée ted de l'année
prochaine vous êtes très honoré ou
prenez le mandat ou discuter à peu les
conditions auxquelles vous vous
retrouvez dans votre espace de coworking
et vous vous dites maintenant comment je
vais procéder
d'abord le plus important il faut penser
au fond donc cette soirée par exemple
elle a un thème ça s'appelle galaxy vous
dites il va falloir trouver un thème
tout seuls dans votre coin votre petit
brassage d'idées c'est quand même pas
évident peut-être que dans l'équipe ici
il ya quelqu'un qui a l'habitude
d'animer des séances qui serait capable
de faire un brainstorming
est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un ici qui serait
capable de faire un brainstorming qui en
a déjà fait 1 je vois quelques doigts
qui se lève au fond vous allez pouvoir
faire du brassage d'idées il y avait
toutes sortes de choses à mais il faut
pas que l'animateur il faut d'autres
personnes aussi pour amener des idées
bon là je pense que c'est ok vous allez
trouver des personnes qui sont d'accord
de donner un peu de leur temps pour que
vous trouviez le thème de la soirée de
l'année prochaine maintenant vous avez
le thème il faut vous trouviez les
orateurs en fonction du thème vous allez
réfléchir à qui peut venir parler
l'année prochaine peut-être que parmi
vous il ya des gens le thème je n'ai pas
assez vous qui allez voir avec votre
équipe qu'est ce que vous allez avoir
comme tel mais peut-être que parmi les
courants il ya des gens qui pourraient
intervenir tuant des compétences qu'ils
ont des ressources qui ont du savoir qui
pourrait amener leur apporter leur
expérience leur vécu messi a personne
qui peut venir apporter sa compétence
comme orateur je suis sûr que parmi vous
il y en a qui connaissent des gens qui
ont entendu parler de gens qui peuvent
venir
assurer le rôle d'orateur pour ted
l'année prochaine quand on a fait le
brainstorming
on était dans l'antre aide maintenant on
est dans le réseau chacun fait
fonctionner son réseau et on trouve des
solutions maintenant vous avez le thème
vous avez les orateurs il faut que vous
pensiez aux choses pratiques le lieu
c'est bon vous allez le refaire ici mais
il va falloir communiquer sur
l'événement il va falloir vous mettiez
vous fassiez un programme que vous vous
mettiez les informations en ligne pour
mettre les informations en ligne il faut
que vous ayez quelqu'un qui soit capable
d'écrire du texte que vous ayez
quelqu'un qui puisse faire le graphisme
vous avez compris un peu comment ça
fonctionne vous allez trouver quelqu'un
pour faire la communication vous allez
trouver quelqu'un pour mettre les
informations en ligne sur le site
internet
vous allez trouver un imprimeur et je
suis sûr que s'il n'y a pas toutes ses
ressources parmi vous vous connaissez
tous des gens qui peuvent répondre à ses
besoins là on va être dans le service il
va falloir payer un peu quand même mais
je suis sûr que tête vous aura donné un
budget ça fait penser qu'il faut trouver
des partenaires des sponsors aussi pour
financer l'événement mais là c'est
facile avec toutes les personnes qui
sont ici je suis sûre que vous avez des
connexions avec des banques avec des
assurances avec
des privés qui ont de l'argent qu'ils
sont prêts à soutenir l'événement qui
croient en tedx alors c'est bon on a
l'argent on a le site internet on a les
informations
il ya sûrement de trois petites choses
que j'ai oublié mais vous vous allez y
penser et maintenant il reste une chose
importante c'est vous en fait c'est le
public
alors qu'est ce qu'on va faire retrouver
le public on va faire fonctionner le
réseau et puis ça va être plein et puis
ça va être mémorable cette soirée alors
voilà c'est comme ça que ça peut
fonctionner dans un espace de coworking
là on est dans la gestion de projets il
peut y avoir toutes sortes de
configuration en fonction des gens qui
sont là les gens qui sont le plus
représenté dans les espaces de coworking
comme je vous l ai dit allez gens qui
sont dans la communication il ya des
créatifs
il ya des graphistes chez moi comme je
vous ai dit il ya un traducteur il ya un
webmaster il ya une spécialiste en
communication sur le web depuis le début
de cette semaine est un chercheur lui il
est en train de s'intéresser à ce qui se
passe en grèce alors je peux vous dire
qu'il a du boulot et c'est ouvert à
toutes sortes de personnalités il peut y
avoir aussi on a des fois un peu dans
l'esprit que c'est forcément des
créatifs qui sont dans des espaces de
coworking mais j'ai aussi une
spécialiste en finance et puis on
pourrait imaginer un comptable une
fiduciaire enfin c'est infini les
possibilités et les gens qui arrivent
dans un espace de coworking
bien souvent ils se sont quand même un
peu renseigné avant ils sont déjà acquis
aux valeurs du cours qui alors quelles
sont ces valeurs du corps qui je vous en
ai déjà parlé de manière informelle la
première de ces valeurs c'est la
durabilité
on a une connexion wifi on a du matériel
et on met toutes ses ressources en
activité à disposition des comores terre
la deuxième valeur c'est la communauté
la communauté
s'est tous les gens qui travaillent dans
un espace de coworking et c'est ce qu'on
essaye de constituer avec ces personnes
en essayant de répondre à leurs besoins
en essayant de répondre à leurs attentes
en essayant de répondre à leurs valeurs
la troisième valeur c'est la coopération
là je crois que vous avez compris j'ai
pas besoin de refaire à d'exposer c'est
bon on peut coopérer dans un espace de
coworking la 4e valeur c'est l'ouverture
on partage des expériences on partage
des idées on s'enrichit mutuellement on
croit et on fait croître son entreprise
et enfin la dernière des valeurs c'est
l'accessibilité
travail est ok mais où quand comment et
avec qui je veux et c'est possible avec
le coworking ces valeurs constituent les
cinq piliers de base du coworking une
fois qu'elles sont en place elles sont
génératrices de créativité d'innovation
de partage des changes et de qualité je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure que le
coworking était né en 2005 à san
francisco en suisse romande le premier
centre de coraux king a été ouvert à
lausanne sel et chloé c'était en 2008 il
a été suivi très vite par la muse à
genève dont vous avez sûrement déjà
entendu parler parce que c'est un
endroit qui est très dynamique qui est
très médiatisée c'est la référence du
coworking en suisse romande et depuis
2009 il a déjà accueilli plus de 400
coopère depuis il ya d'autres centres
qui sont qui se sont ouverts à lausanne
à fribourg à montreux à neuchâtel à
genève également l'espace saint-pry 8
que j'ai fondée il ya une année c'est le
premier c'est le seul à ma connaissance
centre de cooking en valais mais par le
réseau j'ai entendu dire qu'il y avait
un centre qui était en train de se
préparer à sierre qui avait un centre
qui était en train de se préparer à
collombey et qu'il y à un centre qui est
en train de se préparer à sion alors si
vous êtes convaincu par le cours qui
n'hésitez plus allez-y foncez fait
l'expérience